Madonna doesn't like me I don't know why
individual wait someone doesn't love
pink I know it's crazy town who's the
mayor of this crazy town the Queen of
Pop pink how many of you are um Heroes
have you met like I know Madonna was a
big influence for you you admired her
career pink gets into it on the Howard
Stern Show do you know her are you
friends with some of these people you
are not Madonna doesn't like me
she is man
I don't want to sweat the small stuff
anymore this apparently came to light
when she first met Madonna 20 years ago
[Applause]
I think that um she tried to kind of
play me on on Regis and Kelly and I
didn't I'm not you know I'm not the one
so it didn't work out what does that
mean she tried to play well it's just
such a silly story as The Story Goes
pink was excited to meet the material
girl and the feeling was Mutual anyway
this is your idol Madonna right here
all right but it sort of got twisted
around that I was like fangirling and
and was dying to meet Madonna in
actuality she invited me into her
dressing room
and so I just said a joke when Regis
brought me out he's like how does it
feel to me like I mean I heard you're
just falling over yourself backstage how
does it feel I'm like I thought she
wanted to meet me
things went downhill from there et's
reached out to Madonna's rep for comment
it didn't work oh and that didn't work
out for us I love Madonna and
right
I love her no matter what like I I still
love her I love her no matter what like
she was such an inspiration to me pinks
found plenty of drama in the New Year
it's her second rumored beef in the last
week alone well
there's Lady Marmalade during an
interview with BuzzFeed UK pink was
asked to rank her 12 most iconic music
videos
[Music]
and fans thought she dissed Christina
Aguilera I'm gonna put that down here at
12. how come it wasn't very fun to make
I'm all about fun and it was like a lot
of fuss and there were some
personalities Kim and Maya were nice but
pink stepped in ASAP telling fans exyna
had to do with who was on that song If
you don't know by now I'm not shading
someone by telling it over and over and
over what actually happened I've never
been one for the popularity contest kind
of thing and conforming or any of that
that sound familiar if they call you
shocking
scandalous you are definitely on to
something
while pink and Madonna might not be
sharing a stage anytime soon at least
Howard was just kidding In This Moment
listen I got a surprise for you
Madonna's here and she's going to fight
you you're gonna go three rounds and
it's gonna be great
[Music]